Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Huniecam Studio!
The "Spiritual successor" and not sequel to Hunie Pop.
It's not a sequel (It is not canon.)
It's not. (The girls change ages for God's sake.)
It's a game where you have virtual girls and you faunt (fap) over them when they're doing their cam girl thing. *smirks at the memory of Spiderman*
And if you don't know what that is...
*Pauses to think about life choices*
So, as you can probably tell by the top-right corner of the screen
I have played this before. [chuckle]
And- because when it first came out I wanted to see if it was actually worthy of me playing it
And then I got addicted to it - And then I started playing it a lot...
And then I got a super high score and got the diamond dick trophy *looks down in shame*-
ANYWAY [chuckles] We're gonna ignore that fact -
Erg - Don't look at that! *brushes away the shame*
Don't look at my shame!
Don't look at my shame that I played by my -
Oh God! Don't look at THAT shame! Get outta there!
What're you doin'?
Beli, what're you doing?
[Kyu] Oooh, heeey - [Mark] Hiiii.
[Guffaw]
[Guffawing] Oh-oh I -
[While guffawing] Oh-Oh I do.
It's about damn time too, I know you missed me -
Whatever your name was.
*Loud and exaggerated groan at the ramblings of Kyu* Uggggh!
Oh God, I know what I'm doing.
(sure you do, babe)
Uh-huh.
No it's not! You don't know that! *aggressively flips off*
*channels Egoraptor* Aw shit, dude. [half-laugh]
Uh-huh.
Okay - So, I know how to play the game and I'm gonna fill you in on most of this
so most of these tutorials I'm actually gonna skip
But first - we need to pick our first
lady that's going to join us in this adventure - And yes, I've unlocked quite a few outfits -
Everyone ignore that fact and everyone ignore everything that you're going to see now! [Deep inhale of shame]
[Yelling] It's okay to flaunt over virtual girls -
I don't even think "flaunt over" is the proper terminology for that. But it's OKAY. *babbles about shame*
So.
First -
thing that you'll probably notice is Nikki is my girl in this game. She is my jam.
She is my boo. <3
She's my bottom bitch [laughing] :^)
[laugh of shame]
Naw - but, she is super cool in this one because for some reason -
And I don't know why I have an encylopedi-atic knowledge of everyone in the game's bust sizes
AND THEY'RE REAL TO ME! [fist pounds upon desk with force of a thousand Warfstaches]
I CONSIDER THEM PEOPLE AND THAT'S OKAY!
It's not weird...
[game music cuts off - a moment of silence for Mark's dignity]
Anyway - So, in the game, Huniepop, she had C cup boobs... *thinks long and hard about how sad this knowledge is*
And for some reason in this game she now has bangin' double D's. So, we're gonna recruit Nikki.
Cuz Nikki...
Is our boo! *sing-songy at the end* <3
Okay, whatever. Shut up.
*Groan of annoyance. Or moose impression. A shamed moose*
*Yelling* I know!
Okay - I'm gonna skip this tutorial because I actually know how to play the game and I want to get into it.
So you got your girl -
She's in her cute little outfit that I didn't hand pick cuz I'm creepy. I'm not creepy! I swear! (He is)
Anyway,
So you put her in the little slot so now she's workin' for ya.
[Nikki] I'll try not to screw up.
[Mark] So the good thing about this- And what's important to remember is-
these girls have items, and fans, and they can cam.
So...
The whole premise of this one, to make it nice and family-friendly, is that they do "let's plays" in this
[Laughing]
dark, disturbing building. And then they do promotional photos for "thumbnails" in this other building
with the camera on it.
So we're gonna do some "promotional photos" just for a little bit.
And then you gotta click- it's a click-farm game, by the way. You just gotta hold down and click as fast
as you can to get as many things as you can and keep it goin' and keep it rollin'.
*Increasingly annoyed groan of shame*
[Groaning] Duuuuuuuuh!
*Raging groan of impatience and/or shame*
Okay.
So you gotta pay 'em.
I mean -
as much as I would like to h- okay, you guys maybe not have heard this.
Ohh, this is the most boring part!
Good God/Warfstache.
Aight, I'm skippin' all of this.
Screw this. Screw this and screw you! We'll meet up with her back when WE have...
Ju-th-the game DONE!
That's what we're gonna do, because you're with ME now! You're on this journey with ME-
managing a harem of girls doing... "let's plays" in a building...
That's not creepy...
And they're gonna be doing the thing- So, once you do enough "promotional thumbnail photos" for the girl-
and she's collected some "subscribers" *laugh of shame* then... you-you send her into the "let's play" building-
where she makes some "advertising" revenue.
Isn't this wonderful?!
And then you send her to the *struggles to rationalize*  "computer store" where she's gonn- You know, the adult computer store-
where she's gonna go get some stuff.
And - uh, crap.
She's gonna- *laugh* She's gonna get- She's gonna- She gonna eat some "sugar" that way she's gonna be going
twice as fast and it's gonna be super cool. Ya just...
Oh God, I don't even have enough money. (Of course you don't, you blew it all on Spiderman merch.)
By the way, there's an investment screen where you upgrade all the different things that you can do for more
girls employed, more money, more stuff. Right now I'm gonna get a second girl goin'-
because that way we can do twice as much stuff, twice as fast. And if I want it- Oh, it's Beli!
Why is Beli chubby? That doesn't even make any sense.
It's Tiffany or Beli. Beli, Tif- Beli already has a higher pay rate so I'm gonna go with Tiffany
because Tiffany is adorable.
And she's good at let's plays and that's all that's happenin' here! *perverted chuckle*
Also she- like, Tiffany for some reason always was my errand girl.
And that's pretty much the only thing that I had her doing.
Because one of the most important items that you could get is the piggy bank, because if everyone has
a piggy bank, that means... that they-
for some reason-
they have a piggy bank so they're "better at saving their money"?
And then...
You get...
Like- you only have to pay them, like, half as much as you normally do.
Also, it's very important in the beginning to do more in terms of getting fans- aw, shit! Come on!
I don't wanna do this! Okay.
Subscribe pillow- the subscribe pillow also helps because when you're doing your cam shows-
it'll actually make it so you can get half as many fans as you would from a promotional photo shoot as you would
in the cam show.
So, it's good because it does double duty and then you can get much more.
Now, one of the six strategies that you can do
Is remembering that the initial game
It's a lot slower, or it's a lot faster to go through the cam show than it is to do it like later in the game
Because the ta- the cam show takes very little time in the beginning
That it makes it much that it makes it much easier to move forward
Now, what else I'm gonna do is I'm also going to send her to the boutique, get her to shop, and that'll level up her fashion.
And that makes for better thumbnails that other people will appreciate - *feels increasingly more sleazy* and then she'll be gooder at that doing thing.
*regret* And nothing else weird.
Look, her "style" went up.
Come on, gimme a- GOD! I don't wanna-uh, *thinking of a lie* I don't wanna
*laughing with shame* "Microphone"...
Uh, who needs-who needs, a-a "logo head-band"
*groan of shame* UGGHHHH
*grumbling* I'll just get this "microphone" here and then that'll be...
[Tiffany] Sure thing! [Mark] *mocking with shame* SURE THING, sounds good, okay...
I don't even know if they can use items yet. There we go!
That's good. I'll- I'll give her, uh- I'll give [laughing]
Nikki the "microphone" the next time she goes in to make more "thumb-nails"...
Oh I didn't even give her the coke. [laughing] I mean sugar!
Aw goddamnit - aw, she's going right to relaxing
YOU DON'T NEED TO RELAX, NIKKI, WE'VE GOT WORK TO DO.
WE GOTTA DO HIGH SCORES THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
And also, uh,  you will never, ever, ever, ever, ever make more fans in the photo studio
, then you will from just buying advertising, so
One of the biggest things you need to do especially in the early game
is you just need to BUY advertising.
Like every day that you buy advertising,
*Markie groan* God, it sounds so creepy - Everything I do. Everything I do is creepy!
Also I just got an upgrade that allows me to take more money out of the... things.
I know... a lot about this game. And I don't know why, but it's the thing that it is.
*stammers awkwardly*
There's really no other way around it-- I don't want a butt plug!
I don't need a butt plug! That's not why we're doin' this!
*Shame. Shame, Markimoose.* It's supposed to be nicer than this...
And hopefully, hopefully toward, uh, later in the game, you'll get everyone coked up outta their mind.
And that's - that's - That's how people -
That's how - Oh, and she's going to the -  "yoga" club.
She's going to do "pilates"!
Alright, so... We got thaaaaat.
OK so we got a good bit of money and the next thing that we do is productivity, because
One of the key components to this clicker game is that you can hold your mouse down or click really fast if you wanna... destroy your wrist.
On the buildings that people are in, and that means that you can do it faster if you get better productivity.
Then eventually I'm gonna get--
So she's a LITTLE... still a little coked up
We're gonna get another one.
Ooh! I always liked Kyanna! Kyanna was [voice destruction] nice. Oh god. Kyanna was nice,
So I'm going to go with Kyanna.
Okay, so now that I have Kyanna here,
That means,
That I can have TWO people going to the shop
Because for some reason I don't have enough.
Oh, shit- come on! Where's the goddamn piggy bank?!
We don't need this!
WE DOON'T!
Okay.
I guess- I guess everyone can use another butt plug! (laughs)
Why not? Why not!
But- yeaahhh!! A PIGGY BANK!
YES! Okay, so this is great,
Because now I have a piggy bank,
And hopefully Nikki's coke ran out,
Nope, not just yet! But we can toss that out the window
And hope get another, uh- inventory slot
But now SHE, has a piggy bank, so her pay was cut in half!
So I can send her for training again,
So that she can get even MORE fans,
And now I'm gonna send uh, it was..
Nah, I need to get- I need to get piggy banks for  all of them basically.
LONG story short, they need piggy banks, because I need to train them up in early game
When we DON'T have a lot of fans,
We just HAVE to have..
urgh..
We just have to have everything that we need.
Okay.
Y- and you wanna go for the...
"Specialty" (laughs) items before you're doing...
anyting else, because-
THERE YES! ANOTHER PIGGY BANK.
PERFECT!
Better than butt plugs!
Piggy ba.. Piggy banks are way better than butt plugs!
Oh I shoulda given it to-
Ohh... shiet!
You did great I think!
Mayb- Ohh.. f- More cocaine
I MEAN SUGAR! IT'S JUST SUGAR!
Alright, I'm gonna cut to the quick, we're-
Here's- Alright. Here's- here- alright, okay.
Uh- okay. Here. (sniffles)
This isn't a let's play simulator.
Uh (laughs) I'm gonna be perfectly honest with you guys
That's not what this is about.
I wish it were!
But unfortunately, I hate to break it to ya.
This is- This game is about girls... c-c-c camming..
With.. nude.
(laughs) And that's the end of the story! That's what they're doing!
I'm sorry that I've shattered ALL of your dreams,
But...
I hate- It's- It's..
It's- It's just the way the world works.
And it's not.. Y'know it's... It is what it is.
Now we all have to live with that!
So that's what we're gonna do!
We're gonna live with that!
It's going to be fine.
Okay? I know I've just broken all of your hearts in realizing that these girls are going online,
And being naked and such,
But that's the way it is. So just.. y'know.
Okay, we got another piggy bank. Yay! Alright.
But we do -  we do need to upgrade our hardware and our web service to be able to just get more,
And also uh- more ads! More ads means more everything.
We need more ads. Like, those are ESSENTIAL.
I cannot reiterate,
How inssential - essen- *gibberish* if thasngbznb(Zombie Markiplier comes out)
So it's always important to try to speed up time in the building that the most people are in,
Because it spreads it equally for both.
Like, it- it says minus two, but it doesn't just do minus one on each of 'em.
It does minus two for BOTH of them.
So that you wanna make sure that wherever they are,
They are.. doing what they do-
Why do you only have ten fans?!
THIS IS BULLSHIT.
You need more fans, lady.
See, the more you send people to go to do the cam shows,
The longer it takes throughout the game.
So you wanna make the initial ones as valuable as possible with as many fans as possible.
(gasp) Lola!
Lola! Oh, my sweet darling!
Oh, Lola!
Oh I've missed you!
How you doing?
You were always my favorite for some reason, I don't even know why.
But I like you a lot.
Okay, so now Lola is on board,
And I.. I adore Lola!
Lola is awesome! And I'm going to give her a piggy bank right away, and she's going tooo..
Let's see..
Youuu need to relax, youuu need to...
(oooooooooo)
Ahhh.. shoooooop.
Okay,
DOONE. Okay! You did great, Nikki don't worry about a thing!
Everything is fine!
Ah
Why wouldn't it be fine?
You don't need to worry about that at all. Okay. Grrrrr.. Grraaaahhh!!
Okay what I need to do now is I need to, make it so that, uh..
The girls can have two accessories
Which is gonna come after this money that I get
And I definitely need to upgrade the money collection because that just takes up too much time,
And EVENTUALLY! I'm gonna start spam clicking but I'm gonna give Nikki some coooo.. sugar.
Some c-sugar. And she's gonna be fine there
And then I'm- okay, I'm going into super click mode.
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Did you get?
Aaaarggh! Titty sprinkles!
UUAAAAARRRGGGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
It's like *slightly* faster to do this(?)
I'm not saying it's faster, it's just sliiightly faaaster and sometimes,
THAAAAT'S ALL YOU NEED! NN-GAARRHH RR(constipation)
(gives birth)
This is how I got the highest score and I absolutely annihilated my wrist in a million ways.
Just- UAAARRGHH (more babies)
Okay.
Y'know what, it's not worth doing that because I don't wanna scream in your ear for the next,
like, few episodes that this takes
AND YES I'VE GOTTA PLAY IT TO COMPLETION
I ADORE MY VIRTUAL GIRLS!
(gasp) THEY ARE MY LIFE
(gasp) THEY ARE MY LOVE
(gasp) AND THEY ARE EVERYTHING TO ME
I DON'T WANT YOU TO TAKE THEM FROM ME!
(Gasps for air)
Anyway,
Let's send them off to relax and we'll paaause for now!
So THANK YOU EVERYBODY so much for watching. Yes,
I'm (chuckles) going to finish this game and NO! Nothing's going to stand in my way!
So thanks again everybody for watching
And as always, I will see YOU, in the next video.
Buh-bye! *wave of love*
(Please subscribe to Markiplier if you wish! He's a really great guy and will cheer you up every single day.)
(Look at his face.)
(How can you resist that face?)
(Make captioning accurate for those who need it)
(Bye everyone. :) )